cette pile de livres représentent toute
l'oeuvre de georges simenon
l'auteur des célèbres maigret est en ce
moment à paris
motif de ce séjour la publication
précisément de ses oeuvres complètes et
la sortie de son 191e roman le chat est
ce que vous pouvez nous définir ce
qu'est le chat en deux mots eh bien oui
si vous voulez mais ce n'est pas très
drôle ce sont deux vieillards très vieux
couple et qui ont d'ailleurs été tous
les deux mariés avant tout les deux
veuves et qui vivent dans une petite
maison ici à paris et qui se haïssent à
la suite derrière de la mort d'un chat
et il se méfie de l'autre aussi croit
chacun sur votre recherche d'emploi zone
et sont là chacun fait sa cuisine se
parlent pas il communique uniquement par
des petits billets qu'il envoie l'un à
l'autre il ya d'autres épisodes bien
entendu ça semble finir mal mais malgré
toute cette charge de haine je crois en
sac commente avoir écrit un roman
d'amour
j'ai lu deux définitions de genre sinon
la première c on l'a dit vous un avocat
des hommes et la seconde est de vous
lier c'est un raccommodeur de destiner
laquelle préférez-vous celle que vous
avez trouvé bien j'aurais mieux aimé est
un commandeur de destiny mais ce n'est
pas moi en parlant de moi que j'ai dit
cela c'est en parlant de maigret mais je
voudrais être un conte voleurs de
destiner être capable de réconcilier l
les hommes entre eux ou avec même mais
malheureusement je ne suis pas tout ce
que je peux peut-être faire quelquefois
par mes romans
c'est leur montrer qu'ils sont moins
mauvais qu'ils ne croient eux-mêmes et
qu' ils sont aussi moins des cas uniques
que tout le monde plus ou moins a les
mêmes problèmes
drame sur une échelle différente mais
qu'en fait quand lé stylemint
s'égalisent à peu près lorsque vous avez
clip fonds des archives xavier ces gens
qui part exacte avant et vous pensiez à
cette époque que le fait d'écrire
n'était pas une profession mais une
vocation vous le pensez encore
aujourd'hui je le pense encore
aujourd'hui
d'abord parce que guerlain sur 100 sur
100 ou les parias qui réussit et
deuxièmement parce que même pour ceux
qui réussissent
c'est une vie assez pénible on n'est
jamais satisfait de soi
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que je
poussais l'écrit joue à gauche mines et
armand mais 24 heures après je suis
inquiet je me dis qu'il vaut rien et
caetera et que j'ai raté complètement
on n'est jamais sûr de son fait qu'est
ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui d'avoir
vous offre complète parce qu'elles vont
paraître aux éditions rencontre oui bien
je me fait très peur neigera je me
demandais comment le public va pouvoir
absorber tout cela sans s'ennuyer et
c'est toujours un petit peu plus tôt que
la joie et pourquoi continuez vous
écrire parce que vous pourriez vous
dispensez l'écrit aujourd'hui mais
j'aurai toujours plus de dispenser
d'écrire et faire autre chose seulement
1 c'est parce que j'ai besoin d'écrire
lorsque je reste un certain temps sans
écrire je me sens tellement mal à l'aise
je me sens tellement mal que je vais
voir mon métier que je deviens malade
imaginaire et vous sentez mal dans votre
peau ou quatre fois par an ah oui oh oui
d'ailleurs déjà maintenant par exemple
de moi que je n'écris pas eh bien j'ai
hâte de nous voler dans mon bureau et
dans la machine à écrire à me sentir
dans la peau de mes personnages ont lieu
dans la mienne